this map shows the flu is going crazy
levels are really high in most of the
country right now RSV and covet are also
circulating setting up a potential
triple democ this season's triple threat
is taking a toll both on patients and
staff now that who and CDC are worried
about a potential surge in cases of
strep and some Public Health experts say
that the culprit could be the flu here's
why the flu is a virus and it can leave
you more vulnerable to getting bacterial
infections like with Streptococcus
bacteria which causes strep there are
three main reasons for that first flu
makes it easier for bacteria to infect
you it damages little hair-like
structures called cilia that line the
respiratory tract the Cilia can't clean
out or wash out the lungs like they're
used to and the bacteria can get stuck
down there and then they can replicate
and cause more problems second flu
infections also cause inflammation that
starts to break apart the tight links
between cells in the lining of our lungs
which acts as a protective barrier that
allow bugs to come through almost like a
little bug Highway third the flu strains
the immune system so if strep bacteria
managed to infect you the immune system
has a harder time fighting them off
every time there's a flu season there's
going to be a lot more incidence of
strep secondary infections those can
lead to complications like pneumonia or
in very rare cases the toxic shock
syndrome that doctors are seeing in kids
look at all this red and purple this flu
season is particularly bad that's partly
because of the pandemic masking social
distancing and working remotely
protected us against covid but those
precautions also kept us from getting
sick generally and there isn't a lot of
population immunity against many
infections so viruses like RSV in the
flu can now get around more easily the
cases of strep are coming at an unusual
time of year from what's expected it's a
trend we're seeing with RSV and other
infectious diseases since the lockdowns
ended flu cases are spiking really
quickly and that's what might be leaving
us more vulnerable to scrap there's
going to be so many more cases of strep
causing serious infection who was most
at risk well that depends on the kind of
strep the number of children who have
died from strep a across the UK since
September has now risen to 19. and the
CDC is also looking at a possible spike
in strep a related complications in kids
in the U.S children particularly smaller
children have all kinds of different
strains of strep in their nose and
throat every single day that never
causes a problem their immune system can
typically fight them off but things are
more complicated right now thanks to
surges and flu and lower level
population immunity plus it's possible
that strep a could be changing too to
become more invasive all that together
is why we might be seeing a potential
increase in serious strep a cases and
why it's getting a lot of attention but
it's a different family of strep that
typically causes the most problems it's
called streptococcus pneumoniae the vast
majority of flu Seasons influenza isn't
actually the source of death it's the
infection caused by the strep pneumonia
and the pneumonia associated with that
doctors recommend that people 65
60 vaccine against strep pneumoniae to
prevent complications from flu they say
the same is true for people with
compromised immune systems heart disease
or chronic lung conditions but for most
people strep doesn't cause
life-threatening issues it's really rare
to have bad consequences from strep as
opposed to influenza which kills 35
000 to 70 000 people a year that's why
Peter and David said it was really
important to get our flu shots
especially this year and right now
vaccination rates for flu are pretty low
so how do we prevent all this it's
simple wash your hands wear a mask and
get your flu shot and if you do end up
testing positive for strep antibiotics
work really well remember regardless of
what you have stay home so you don't
pass it on infections aren't mutually
exclusive just because you just got over
one illness doesn't mean you're immune
to others
[Music]